okay number one we've got 5x minus one
over x squared minus X minus two the
first thing you want to do is you want
to look at this and look at the highest
power term in the numerator the highest
power term in the denominator and you
want to ask yourself is this an improper
fraction if the degree of the highest
power term in the numerator is the same
okay we're higher then it's an improper
fraction you're gonna have to do long
division first and we'll talk about that
in example number five but for this one
you can see that it's actually the
denominators degree that is higher so
this is not an improper fraction so the
next thing we want to do is we want to
factor the denominator as much as you
can so here you can see that this is
going to factor 2x minus 2 and X plus
one okay so what I'm going to do is I'm
just going to kind of draw like a line
through that this is our new denominator
and you can see when you look at these
denominators that these are what they
call distinct meaning different linear
factors linear meaning like either to
the first degree so what we're going to
do is we're going to break this up into
our partial fractions like so we've got
X minus 2 and we also have X plus 1 and
what you want is you want the numerators
power to be one degree lower than the
denominators highest power so in this
case this is first degree really want
this to be a constant so I'm gonna make
this the constant a and here we have X
to the first we're gonna want to make
this the constant B now you want to pick
a different variable so now what we're
doing is we're basically breaking this
down into partial fractions these are a
little bit simpler to work with when you
get to some types of problems like in
calculus where you're doing integration
these might be easier to work with
individually as opposed to this large or
more complicated fraction so now what
we're gonna do is we're gonna find out
what are our a values and our B values
well we're gonna treat this like an
equation and what we're gonna do is
we're going to clear the denominators
okay the best way to do that is to
multiply through by the common
denominator now the common denominator
is going to be this X minus 2 X plus 1
this is our least common multiple so
what I'm going to do is I'm just going
to write that over here X minus 2 times
X plus 1 and what we're going to do is
we're going to think of this as a group
and we're going to distribute it to here
we're going to distribute it to here
we're gonna distribute
the reason it works is because you're
multiplying both sides by that same
quantity so we're not changing the
equation we're just changing the way
that it looks so when we distribute this
X minus 2 times X plus 1 times this
first fraction you can see that the
denominators are going to cancel with
ease here in the numerator which is just
going to leave us with 5x minus 1 when
we distribute this to this fraction you
can see that X minus 2's are gonna
cancel
see denominator and numerator and that's
just gonna leave us with a times X plus
1 and then over here when we distribute
it to this last fraction you can see the
X plus 1s are gonna cancel a numerator
denominator and we're just going to have
B times X minus 2 so now I've got a
little bit simpler equation to work with
what we're gonna do in this particular
example is I'm going to show you how to
pick strategic values of X some teachers
refer this as finding the zeros and what
you're doing is you're just setting this
group here or this group okay these
factors equal to 0 so for example if I
set X plus 1 equal to 0 I get negative 1
so what I'm going to do is I'm just
gonna say let's let X equal negative 1
and if I put negative 1 in here I get
negative 5 minus 1 is negative 6
if I put negative 1 in here for X I get
0 times a which is just 0 that cancels
out and negative 1 minus 2 is negative 3
times B gives us negative B times 3 okay
or negative 3 B I should say so now what
we want to do is we want to divide both
sides by negative 3 and you can see that
B is equal to 2 okay now we know what B
is we need to find out what a is we
already let X equal negative 1 let's set
this factor equal to 0 let's let X equal
2 and again the reason that we're doing
that is because 2 minus 2 is 0 that's
going to cancel out this whole term and
so then that'll allow us to solve for a
this doesn't work in every problem and
I'll show you some other examples but
sometimes this is a quicker way to do it
so let's go ahead and do that now we're
gonna let X equal to let me just write
that down and if we put 2 in here you
can see we're gonna get 2 times 5 is 10
minus 1 is 9 and over here we have 2
plus 1 is 3 times a is 3 a and over here
are 2 minus 2 is 0 times B is 0
that just cancels out so you can see
here if we divide both sides by three a
is coming out to three okay now we know
what our eight and our B value are the
last step that you're going to want to
do is just rewrite this showing your
result so I'm just going to say over
here are 5x minus 1 all divided by x
squared minus X minus 2 is equal to a
which is 3 over X minus 2 plus our B
value which we said was 2 over X plus 1
and this is your partial fraction
decomposition if you want to check your
work go ahead and combine these two
fractions together getting a common
denominator and you'll see that it
equals this one on the left and you got
it okay number two we have a little bit
more challenging problem now we've got
2x squared minus 11x plus 17 all over
this denominator the first thing you
want to do is you want to ask yourself
is this an improper fraction and the way
you do that is you look at the highest
power term in the numerator the highest
power term in the denominator and if
this one in the numerator is higher or
equal to the highest power term in the
denominator then you have an improper
fraction you have to do polynomial long
division or synthetic division depending
on the problem to rewrite it okay and
then you'll proceed from there to do the
partial fraction decomposition but here
you can see that this denominators power
is higher than the numerator it's not
improper the next thing we want to do is
we want to factor that denominator as
much as we can now you can see there's
four terms here normally I would try
factoring by grouping unfortunately this
one doesn't factor by grouping so what
we're gonna have to do is use our
rational root theorem or rational zero
theorem and you take all the factors of
9 over all factors of leading
coefficient 1 positive or negative and
you test those out using synthetic
division so let me just do that if you
need to review the rational root theorem
you can check that out on my channel but
let me just show you that part really
quick cuz sometimes what you just can
give you ones that are not factored
sometimes the dynamic factored so it'd
be a little bit easier but let me just
do the synthetic division here we
multiply on the diagonal we add straight
down we both play in the diagonal we add
straight down we multiply on the
diagonal when we add straight down say
we have a zero remainder that tells us
that one is
zero X minus 1 is a factor and it brings
it down from X cubed - x squared and we
can factor this further this is going to
be X minus 3 times X minus 3 times X
minus 1 now we've got it completely
factored and what you'll notice in this
problem is that we have an X minus 3
twice this is what's called a repeated
linear factor linear meaning
first-degree so how do we handle
repeated linear factor what we're gonna
do is we're gonna go over here to our
partial fraction decomposition we've got
X minus 1 is one of our denominators
okay we've got X minus 3 as one of our
denominators and we have X minus 3
squared now if there was three X minus
3s then we would also have an X minus
three cubed and what you're doing is
you're saying well you know when I
combine these together you know I have
to consider that there could be an X
minus 3 and an X minus 3 squared or
there might just be an X minus 3 squared
and not this X minus 3 but we won't know
yet until we do you know all the
arithmetic here so this is our breakdown
and again we've got a we've got B and
we've got C so you just whatever is in
the parentheses here you just want this
numerator to be one degree lower since
that's first-degree that's going to be a
constant okay so now we have our basic
set up the rest we just have to clear
the denominators and solve the equation
for a B and C and then we've got our
partial fraction decomposition now this
is where students sometimes get stuck
and all the arithmetic so I want to show
you the strategy here we're going to
multiply through by the common
denominator and remember this factored
as X minus 1 X minus 3 times X minus 3
or X minus 3 squares I'm just going to
draw a line through this this is our new
denominator so if we multiply through
each one of these terms we're
multiplying the left side and right side
by X minus 1 X minus 3 squared what's
going to happen is it's going to clear
the denominator so let me just write
that over here X minus 1 and X minus 3
squared so we're going to distribute to
this first fraction which is just going
to give us 2x squared minus 11x plus 17
when we distribute to here
x- ones are going to cancel so we're
going to have a times X minus three
squared when we distribute to this
fraction one of the X minus threes and
one of the X minus threes is going to
cancel leaving us B times X minus 1 X
minus 3 and then we distribute to here
the last term the X minus 3 squares are
going to cancel so we're just going to
have C times X minus 1 okay so this is
the equation we're going to be solving
we're gonna be picking strategic values
of ax to eliminate some of these terms
so it allows us to solve for either a B
or C now a good first step here excuse
me is let's let X equal 1 so if we let X
equals 1 that's going to make this whole
group equal to 0 it's gonna make this
whole group equal to 0 which is going to
allow us to solve for a so if we put 1
in for X make sure you put it in to both
sides of the equation you're gonna get 2
minus 11
mmm which is negative 9 plus 17 which is
8 so we have 8 equals one minus 3 which
is negative 2 square which is 4 so we
get 4a and we said that these terms
cancels so you can see that a is equal
to 2 okay great so now we want to let X
equal 3 now why three because three is
going to cancel out this group 3 is
going to cancel out this group because
if this is 0 0 times anything is 0 and
that's going to give us 3 minus 1 is 2 C
so we have to C equals 3 squared is 9
times 2 is 18 plus 17 is 35 minus 33 is
2 so you can see that we have C is equal
to 1 now all we have to do is solve for
B now you're probably saying at this
point Mario what are we going to do
we've already used our zeros we can be
made this equal to 0 3 we made this
equal to 0 by letting X equal 1 let's
just let X equal 0 okay so if we let X
equal 0 0 is always usually easy to work
with because this is going to make this
0 this 0 that's 17 and that's going to
be let's see 0 minus 3 is negative 3
squared which is 9 times a which is 2 so
that's 18 over here we have negative 1
times negative 3 is 3 B whoops and then
this over here is going
to be zero minus negative one is
negative one times C which is one so
that gives us negative one so now all we
have left to solve for is B and you can
see we have 17 and 17 so if we subtract
17 from both sides we get 3 B is equal
to 0 divide both sides by 3 and we get B
is equal to 0 and so that's kind of
interesting so in this particular one
this term you know is just 0 we didn't
actually have that term sometimes you
will have an X minus 3 and an X minus 3
squared term so you want to make sure
you consider both of those cases but
let's go ahead and write our final
result so our final result of our
partial fraction decomposition is you
want to write the original rational
expression the original fraction which
was x cubed minus 7 x squared plus 15 X
minus 9 and the reason you're doing this
is because somebody might have made this
B and this a or you know they might have
changed the variables so your a B and C
might be different than your neighbors a
B and C so here we've got 2 over X minus
1 B was 0 so I'm not going to write that
term and then C is 1 over X minus 3 the
quantity squared
that's your partial fraction
decomposition and you got it if you want
to check your work get a common
denominator combine these back into one
fraction and you're gonna get back the
original rational expression okay number
three we've got seven x squared minus 7x
plus 18 all over X cubed plus 8 well
first thing you want to do like normal
is you want to look and see is this an
improper fraction well we can see that
the degree in the denominator is higher
than the degree in the numerator so this
is not an improper fraction the next
step is to factor the denominator as
much as you can and one thing you'll
notice here is that this is a sum of two
perfect cubes so you want to review your
factoring sum of two cubes if you
haven't memorized that already this is
going to factor 2x + 2 x squared - 2 x +
2 squared which is 4 so I'm just going
to cross that out this is equal to this
denominator here we can't factor this
trinomial any further so that's as far
as we can go with this factorization now
one thing that you'll notice here is
that we have a linear factor C this is
to the first degree and we have what's
called a quadratic or a second degree
actor so this is the different than the
ones we've worked with so far so we're
gonna do this as we've got X plus 2 okay
is one of our denominators in our other
fraction we're gonna have a denominator
of x squared minus 2x plus 4 and again
remember if you were to combine these
together into one fraction you have to
get a common denominator this would be
your common denominator so all we're
doing is breaking this down into partial
fractions now remember this is a
first-degree like X to the first want
the numerator to be one degree less so
I'm gonna make this a constant and we're
just gonna call it the a over here we
have a second-degree denominator so we
want this to be one degree less so I'm
gonna make this linear BX plus C now
what would happen if this was a cubic X
cubed then I would do BX squared plus CX
Plus D what would happen if this was X
to the fourth then I would do B X cubed
plus CX squared plus D X plus e so you
understand how that works so it's always
one degree less and you want to go down
in descending order to the constant so
now we've got our partial fractions the
only thing we need to do now the only
thing really this is the main part of
the problem this is the toughest part is
clearing the denominators and solving
for our a B and C in this case so we
know what our common denominator is it's
this X plus 2x squared minus 2x plus 4
so what we're going to do is we're going
to multiply the left side and the right
side of the equation by that common
denominator to clear the denominator so
if I distribute this to the first
fraction these are gonna cancel right so
that's going to leave us with 7x squared
minus 7x plus 18 if we distribute it to
this term here the X plus twos are going
to cancel leaving us with a times x
squared minus 2x plus 4 if we distribute
to here the extra minus 2x plus fours
are gonna cancel leaving us with BX plus
C times X plus 2 okay so you're with me
so far
so now we want to do is we're gonna do a
little different technique here we're
not going to pick strategic values of X
the zeros we're gonna actually simplify
this out a little bit so I'm gonna
distribute the a so I get ax squared
minus 2a X plus 4a I'm just distributing
here I'm going to foil or just do the
distributive property twice that's be x
squared plus 2b
X plus C X plus 2c okay and now what I'm
going to do is I'm going to collect like
terms so what I mean by that is you see
how we have ax squared + BX squared so
I'm going to write this as a + b times x
squared because you can see this will be
ax squared plus BX prime which are these
two terms let's collect the ones that
have an X in them now so we've got this
one and this one and this one so here
I'm going to write this as negative 2a
plus 2b plus C times ax okay and again
you can see I just factored out the ax
out of all three of these terms and then
now we're just left with the constants
which you can see we've got 4a and to C
so I'm going to say plus 4a plus 2c is
equal to this over here 7x squared minus
7x plus 18 okay so now what we're going
to do is we're going to set the x
squared is equal to each other see how
this is a plus BX squared and this is 7x
squared so one of our equations is going
to be a plus B is equal to 7 we've got
over here see these X's these X terms
you want to set equal to each other so
we have negative 2a plus 2b plus C is
equal to the negative 7 and then we want
to set our constant terms on the left
side on the right side equal to each
other so we have 4a plus 2c is equal to
18 so now all we have to do is solve the
system of equations and there's a lot of
different techniques you already know
about how to solve systems of equations
like matrices and Kramer's rule and
elimination method and etc but I think
I'm gonna do for this one is I'm just
going to do the elimination method and
what you'll notice here is is that we
have let's see we've got this first
equation just has a and B's in it okay
the second and third equations you've
got these ones that have C's let's see
if we can eliminate the C's by combining
the second and third equation so I'm
going to multiply this middle
by negative two that way I have to see a
negative to see when I add those
together the C's will cancel leaving us
with an equation with just days and B's
which we then can combine with the first
equation okay so if I multiply by
negative two
and so we get 4a let's see this is going
to give us a negative 4b we get a
negative 2 C and we get positive 14 so
in the bottom equation I'm just going to
bring it over we have 4a plus 2c is
equal to 18 and now you can see if we
add straight down here we get let's see
we get 8a we've got negative 4b the C's
cancel and we get 32 so notice we have a
and B the first equation also has an A
and B in it so let me bring that down
here a plus B is equal to 7 and what we
want to do now is we want to combine
these to eliminate the A's of the B so
I'm gonna multiply the bottom equation
by a 4 so that's going to give us 4 a +
4 B is equal to 28 and so now what we
can do is let me just bring this
equation down here we've got 8 a minus 4
B is equal to 32 if we combine these
together we get 12a the B's cancel and
we get 60 divided by 12 you can see that
a is equal to 5 okay so now we have to
do is just put the 5 back in let's just
say we put it in here so that means that
B is equal to 2 okay so we know B is
equal to 2 and now we know a and B let's
solve for C so if a is 5 that's going to
make this 20 okay and then if we
subtract 20 from both sides we get
negative 2 so that means that C is equal
to negative 1 so we have our a B and C
the last thing we need to do is rewrite
our partial fractions so let me go ahead
and do that I'll put it right here okay
so we've got 7x squared minus 7x plus 18
all divided by X cubed plus 8 and that
equals a which was 5 over X plus 2 plus
B which is 2 X C was negative 1 all
divided by x squared minus 2x plus
or if you want to double-check your work
you can combine these two fractions
together by getting a common denominator
and you'll get back that original
rational expression okay number four you
can see we've got an X to the fourth
degree in the numerator the denominator
luckily this one's already been factored
for us but notice we have x squared
square which is X to the fourth times
this acts as X to the fifth since we
have a fifth degree in the denominator a
fourth degree in the numerator this is
not an improper fraction if the
numerator was the same power or higher
than the greatest degree in the
denominator then it would be improperly
to have to do our long division first so
this was not improper the next thing we
want to do since it's already factored
for us is we want to just break it up
into our partial fractions and now what
we have here is we have a quadratic see
how it's a second-degree squared so this
is called a repeated quadratic type of
problem and then we also have a linear
factor so way we're gonna hit our
repeated quadratic factor is we've got x
squared plus two okay we also are gonna
have to consider that it could be you
know x squared plus two squared so when
you combine these together to get a
common you know you're gonna have x
squared plus two squared and then also
we've got the X plus three you now see
this was x squared plus two cubed then
we'd have to have x squared plus two to
the first x squared plus two to the
second and another x squared plus two to
the third right so you want to consider
all three of those cases notice how this
is a second-degree so in our numerator
we want this to be one degree lower so
that's why I have ax plus B if this is
like cubic I'd have to do ax squared
plus BX plus C same thing here you take
what's on the inside that's a quadratic
so we want this to be linear so CX plus
D and over here this is linear actually
the first I just want this to be a
constant e make sure you don't repeat
any of your variables here okay
and so now what we have to do is just go
ahead and clear the denominators by
multiplying through by this common
denominator which is the x squared plus
two squared times X plus three so if we
distribute this to the first fraction
that's going to clear the denominator or
we're just gonna be left with negative x
to the fourth plus three x cubed plus
six x squared plus 11x plus 20 this is
probably one of the toughest problem
when you have the repeated quadratic
because you can see you've got a lot of
variables here but I'm going to show you
how to work with this so when we
distribute it to this next one see how
the x squared plus two one of these
cancels with this one so you just are
left with ax plus B times x squared plus
2 and X plus 3 when you distribute to
this one the x squared plus 2 squared is
canceled so you just have a CX Plus D
times an X plus 3 and when you
distribute to this one the X plus 3s
cancel and you just have an e times x
squared plus 2 squared ok so now we want
to pull all this out and so what we want
to do here is let's start by multiplying
these together we've got X cubed plus 3x
squared plus 2x plus 6 all multiplied by
the ax plus B and then over here if we
foil this out we distribute the C X we
get CX squared plus 3 CX Plus D X plus 3
D and then if we multiply this part out
we have e times X to the fourth plus 4 x
squared plus 4 ok now if we distribute
the ax we get a X to the 4th plus 3 a X
cubed plus 2 ay x squared plus 6x and if
we distribute the B we get plus B X
cubed plus 3b x squared plus 2 B X plus
6 B ok and so I'm just going to cross
this out so we have all this plus all of
this and if we distribute the e we get e
X to the 4th plus 4 e x squared plus 4 e
let's cross that out that's equal to
this so we want to do is want to combine
or group like terms so we've got our X
to the fourth so a X to the fourth and e
x to the fourth so that's going to be a
plus e times X to the fourth
ok let's group our X cubes now we've got
three X cubed so that's going to be
three a let's see other excuse we've got
plus B
X cubed and that's that's it and then
for the X Squared's we've got two ax
squared plus 3b x squared plus CX
squared plus 4e x squared okay and then
for our X's we have 6a X plus 2 B X plus
3 C X plus D X and then for our
constants we have 6 B and we've got C 3
D and we have 4 e okay so now what we
want to do is we want to set these equal
to the left side of the equation so see
how this is negative 1 X to the fourth
and this is 8 plus E X to the fourth we
want to set those coefficients equal so
we have let's write it over here we've
got a plus e equals a negative 1 okay
now for the X cubes we have three a plus
1 B is equal to 3 X cubed so I'll just
say equals 3 and then for the X
Squared's we have 2a plus 3b plus C plus
4 E is equal to 11 and then for the X's
we have 6 a plus 2b plus 3 C plus D is
equal to 11
I'm sorry is equal to this one was 6
okay equals 6 that's X Squared's this is
11 that's for the X's and then for the
constants equals 20 we have 6 B plus 3 D
plus 4 E is equal to 20 so notice what
we have here is we have five variables a
B C D and E we have 5 equations so we
can solve the system for
B C D and E now you can do this a lot of
different ways but what I want to show
you is how to use the graphing
calculator and use the row reduce
echelon form so I'm going to do is I'm
going to write this as an Augmented
matrix I'm going to take the coefficient
so we've got 1 a 0 B 0 C 0 D 1 e is
equal to negative 1
ok and then for this one we've got 3 a 1
B 0 C 0 D 0 e equals 3 we've got 2 a 3 B
1 C 0 D 4 e equals 6 and then over here
we've got 6 a 2 B 3 C 1 D and 0 E is
equal to 11 and then the last equation
we have 0 a we have 6 B and then we've
got 0 C 0 actually 3 D and for e so
we've got 3 d 4 E and that equals 20 so
let's go ahead and put this into our
graphing calculator I'll show you that
next so what you want to do is you want
to go over to second and then matrix
which is on the left hand side here and
what we're going to do is we're going to
arrow to the right where it says edit
and we're gonna press ENTER and you can
see what we want as a 5 by 6 we want 5
rows and we want 6 columns and I entered
the coefficients in our system on the
left hand side of the matrix I entered
the solutions here and that right column
of the Augmented matrix so now what we
want to do is we want to press this this
is really important you want to press
2nd quit that takes you back to the home
screen you want to press then second
Matrix and then what you want to do is
you want to go to the math so arrow to
the right and you want to arrow down to
where it says row reduced echelon form
rref it's letter B here if we press
ENTER and we go back to the matrix
second Matrix we want to select matrix a
so I'm going to press ENTER for matrix a
press ENTER one more time and then
there's our row reduced echelon form
okay so you can see we've figured out
that our a value is 0 our be us 3 our C
is 1 or D is 2 in our ears
negative one if we put those back in
we've got our partial fraction
decompositions so since a was 0 that
means this ax is zero so we just had B
which is 3 over x squared plus 2 we have
our C value which is 1 so that it's 1 X
plus 2 or you could just say X plus 2
over X 4 plus 2 squared and then our
evaluative one so I just wrote this as
minus 1 over X plus 3 and you've got
your partial fraction decomposition and
you got it ok for number 5 what you'll
notice or what jumps out at you at you
right away is that you see how this is a
fourth degree in the numerator only a
second degree in the denominator when
this numerators degree is greater than
or equal to the highest degree in the
denominator you have an improper
fraction on your hands and what you want
to do is you want to do polynomial long
division so I'm going to see how many
times is x squared minus 4
go into X to the fourth plus 2x cubed
minus 4 x squared minus 7x minus 6 so if
you need to review polynomial long
division but how many times is x squared
going to X to the fourth it goes in
there x squared times if I distribute
the x squared I get X to the fourth
minus 4 x squared and then we subtract
which is like changing the signs of the
opposite and adding so these cancel out
these cancel out we have 2x cubed minus
7x minus 6 how many times does x squared
go into 2 X cubed it goes in 2x times if
we distribute that 2 X now we get 2x
cubed minus 8x and if we subtract which
is like changing the signs and adding
you can see that these cancel and we get
X minus 6 and notice that this is X to
the first this is x squared since this
is a lower degree that's a remainder and
we put the remainder over the divisor
and now what we want to do is we want to
do our partial fraction decomposition on
this right here okay this fraction so
let's go ahead and jump down here we've
got X minus 6 over x squared minus 4 but
notice that x squared minus 4 is
actually a difference of two squares X
plus 2 X minus 2 so I'm just going to
cross that out and when we break this
down you can see these are distinct
linear factors so what we have is we
have X plus 2 and X minus 2
and because these are linear the
numerator is going to be one degree
lower it's going to be a constant and
all we have to do now is multiply
through by the common denominator which
is going to be X plus 2 X minus 2 if we
distribute to the first fraction the X
plus 2 X minus 2's cancel leaving us
with X minus 6 and we distribute two
here you can see the X plus twos cancel
we have a times X minus 2 if we
distribute to the this fraction here the
X minus 2's cancel and we have B times X
plus 2 now by picking strategic values
of X if we let X equal to 2 minus 2 is 0
that cancels out this group 2 plus 2 is
4 so we get 4 B equals negative 4 so
that means that B is negative 1 and if
we let a X equal negative 2 that's going
to make this group 0 so that's going to
be negative 4 a is equal to negative 8
divided by negative 4 and you can see
that a is equal to positive 2
so that means that this fraction here is
actually equal to let's see a which is 2
over X plus 2 plus negative 1 over X
minus 2 but remember this is the part
that students sometimes forget is that
we also had this x squared plus 2x so
really if we take this whole fraction we
break it down it's going to break down
into x squared plus 2 X plus this
fraction which we broke it down into
this which remember a was 2 over X plus
2 and then B was negative 1 so I'm just
going to write this as a minus 1 over X
minus 2 and that's your complete partial
fraction decomposition if you were to
get common denominators for all these
terms combine them together into one
fraction you would get the original back
so that's how you do the improper
fraction ones